>>> SHOULD PRESIDENT BIDEN RUN
AGAIN IN 2024?
>> YES.
>> MR. NADLER?
>> TOO EARLY TO SAY.
DOESN'T SERVE THE PURPOSE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO -- TO DEAL
WITH THAT UNTIL AFTER THE
MIDTERMS.
>> MS. MALONEY?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE HE'S RUNNING
FOR REELECTION.
>>> THAT WAS DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSWOMAN CAROLYN MALONEY IN
THE CONGRESSIONAL PRIMARY DEBATE
IN NEW YORK'S 12th CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICT AND SHE IS WITH US NOW.
YOU TOOK HEAT FOR THOSE
COMMENTS.
YOU DID LATER SAY THAT IF
PRESIDENT BIDEN DOES RUN FOR
REELECTION YOU'RE GOING TO BACK
HIM, BUT WHY DID YOU SAY THAT?
WHY DO YOU THINK HE'S NOT GOING
TO RUN FOR REELECTION?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, I THINK
WE OWE A TREMENDOUS DEBT OF
GRATITUDE TO PRESIDENT BIDEN.
HE SAVED THE COUNTRY BY RUNNING
AGAINST FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND HE DEFEATED HIM AND HE HAS
ALSO DONE AN INCREDIBLE JOB AS
PRESIDENT, PASSING THE BUILD
BACK BETTER -- THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN, THE INFRASTRUCTURE
PLAN AND NOW THE
INFRASTRUCTURE -- THE INFLATION
REDUCTION PLAN WHICH IS BASED
OFF THE BUILD BACK BETTER.
SO I THINK HE'S DONE AN
INCREDIBLE JOB AND IS GIVING US
A RECORD TO RUN ON IN THE '22
ELECTIONS.
LET'S FINISH THE '22 ELECTIONS
BEFORE WE GET TO '24.
>> BUT WHY DO YOU THINK HE'S NOT
RUNNING?
>> THAT WAS JUST MY OWN PERSONAL
BELIEF WHICH I'M NOT GOING TO --
BUT I WILL SUPPORT HIM IF HE
RUNS AND IT'S TOTALLY HIS
DECISION.
>> BUT WHY DO YOU HAVE THAT
PERSONAL BELIEF?
>> WELL, WE ARE ALL ENTITLED TO
HAVE OUR OWN INFORMATION AND OUR
OWN BELIEFS, BUT I WILL SUPPORT
HIM IF HE RUNS FOR PRESIDENT.
HE'S ALREADY BEEN AN OUTSTANDING
PRESIDENT.
HE'S HELPED THE CITY
TREMENDOUSLY WITH THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN, IT BROUGHT $5.8
BILLION TO OUR CITY, KEPT OUR
HOSPITALS, OUR TRAINS RUNNING,
HELPED THE SMALL BUSINESSES AND
PROVIDED FREE VACCINES TO
EVERYONE.
AND THE NEW BILL THAT HE HAS
COME OUT WITH I THINK IS REALLY
EXCITING, THE INFLATION
REDUCTION BILL WHICH WILL ALLOW
MEDICARE TO NEGOTIATE LOWER DRUG
PRICES, THAT WILL BE EXTREMELY
HELPFUL, AND HAS THE FIRST AND
MOST LARGEST INVESTMENT IN
GREENING OF AMERICA.
AND I PARTICULARLY LIKE HIS --
HIS MOVE TO ELECTRIFY THE POSTAL
FLEET, THAT'S THE SECOND-LARGEST
FLEET IN AMERICA, AND IT WILL
MOVE US TOWARDS GREEN ENERGY.
HE CAN USE THE POSTAL OFFICES AS
CHARGING STATIONS AND 70% OF THE
TOXIC FUMES THAT ARE POLLUTING
THE ENVIRONMENT COME FROM FOSSIL
FUELS SO IT WILL REDUCE THAT
TREMENDOUSLY.
THANK YOU, PRESIDENT BIDEN.
>> OKAY.
YOU ARE A FAN OF HIS.
YOU ARE A FAN OF HIS, TO BE
CLEAR, EVEN AS YOU SAID THAT YOU
THINK HE WON'T BE RUNNING.
>> I PROBABLY SHOULD -- MR.
PRESIDENT, I APOLOGIZE.
I WANT YOU TO RUN.
I HAPPEN TO THINK YOU WON'T BE
RUNNING, BUT WHEN YOU RUN OR IF
YOU RUN, I WILL BE THERE 100%.
YOU HAVE DESERVED IT.
YOU ARE A GREAT PRESIDENT AND
THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING YOU'VE
DONE FOR MY STATE AND ALL THE
STATES AND ALL THE CITIES IN
AMERICA.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
>> I THINK THAT DEBATE MAY HAVE
BEEN -- WE WILL SEE IF HE HEARS
THAT.
I BET HE PROBABLY WILL, BUT I
THINK THAT DEBATE MAY HAVE BEEN
THE ENTRY POINT FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE WATCHING THIS RACE AND
THEN THEY START TO REALIZE,
WAIT, WHY IS JERRY NADLER AND
CONGRESSWOMAN MALONEY, WHY ARE
THEY RUNNING AGAINST EACH OTHER.
THERE WAS A REDISTRICTING FOR
OBVIOUSLY NEW YORK AND HE
ACTUALLY NOW LIVES IN YOUR
DISTRICT.
HE COULD HAVE RUN IN THE 10th
STILL, HIS OLD DISTRICT, BUT NOW
HERE YOU ARE RUNNING AGAINST
EACH OTHER IN THE 12th.
AND IT'S GOTTEN PRETTY TESTY.
CASE IN POINT, A TWEET THAT YOU
PUT OUT QUESTIONING WHERE NADLER
WAS ON THE EXTENSION OF A SUBWAY
PROJECT, A VERY IMPORTANT ONE
THAT MATTERS TO A LOT OF NEW
YORKERS ON THE EAST SIDE OF
MANHATTAN.
HE REPLIED, HERE I AM, I'M
STANDING RIGHT NEXT TO YOU, A
PICTURE FROM THE SAME EVENT
WHERE HE WAS ABOVE --
ABOVEGROUND WITH YOU.
WHY HAS IT GOTTEN TO THIS POINT
WHERE YOU GUYS ARE TIT FOR TAT
ON TWITTER AND IT'S GETTING KIND
OF TESTY?
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK IT'S --
WE'RE FRIENDS.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT IT
HAPPENED.
I AM RUNNING IN THE 12th
DISTRICT, 60% OF IT IS THE 12th
DISTRICT, THE DISTRICT THAT I
REPRESENT NOW.
HE COULD HAVE EASILY RUN IN THE
10th BECAUSE HIS -- HIS
CONGRESSIONAL OFFICE IS IN THE
10th AND THE PROPERTY THAT HE
REPRESENTED BEFORE IS IN THE
10th.
I EXPECTED HIM TO RUN IN THE
I WAS VERY SURPRISED WHEN HE
TWEETED OUT THAT HE WAS RUNNING
IN THE 12th.
BUT NOW WE'RE RUNNING, BUT HE
HAD TO CLAIM CREDIT FOR THE
SECOND AVENUE SUBWAY, WHICH IS
FINE WITH ME, IT'S ON THE EAST
SIDE AND I WORKED VERY HARD ON T
IT WAS MY TOP PRIORITY FOR
YEARS, IT WAS THE ONLY SUBWAY
THAT'S BEEN BUILT SINCE I'VE
BEEN IN CONGRESS, NOT IN THE
CITY, NOT IN THE STATE, BUT THE
WHOLE COUNTRY.
BUT I SORT OF AGREE NOW WITH THE
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMAN, YOU CAN
DO A LOT MORE IF YOU JUST LET
EVERYBODY CLAIM CREDIT.
HE IS ENTITLED TO CLAIM CREDIT
FOR IT IF HE WANTS TORQUES MY
ONLY QUESTION IS WHY DIDN'T HE
BUILD SOMETHING ON THE WEST
SIDE?
HE CAME TO CONGRESS SAYING HE
WANTED TO BUILD A RAIL FREIGHT
TUNNEL, 30 YEARS HE STILL HASN'T
BUILT T I BUILT THE SUBWAY, HE
CAN CLAIM CREDIT FOR T BUT FOR
THE WEST SIDE HE SHOULD HAVE
BUILT HIS TUNNEL.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS WORK ON IT
EVERY DAY.
>> CONGRESSWOMAN, WE ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT HAPPENS
IN THIS RACE, IT'S CAPTURING A
LOT OF ATTENTION.
CAROLYN MALONEY, WE APPRECIATE
YOU BEING WITH US.
>> WELL, THANK YOU.